um will farell was her commencement
speaker at Harvard in 2003 so here is
proof Harvard University's graduating
class of
2003 without a doubt the finest most
talented group of sexual beings this
great land has to
offer I love him so
much like everything about it the
physicality of everything about it do
remember that day obviously oh my God so
well I remember it so well I'm I've been
such a big fan of his forever and then
he did this whole bit where it was like
as if he was supposed to speak at a
yacht club and not at Harvard and he was
just like it was so great and then when
I got to meet him on this I was like do
you remember when you and he was like I
didn't realize you were you were there
that day you were one of the sexual
beings was like aren't we all aren't we
all it was amazing I just thought that
was so funny and then ended up working
together that's so cool full circle yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
amazing thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home